Avengers in-game could quite possibly be
a movie that has some of the most hidden
Easter eggs of all time how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we have
already discovered over 500 Easter eggs
callbacks and references in Avengers
endgame and today we get to add one more
as an easter egg has been found in
Avengers in game that references an old
MCU villain this Avengers in-game
villain Easter Egg was only revealed
thanks to a visual effects breakdown
that was recently released so I'll go
ahead and show the clip and break it all
down quick reminder if you'd like a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter so as you can see from this clip
this Easter Egg was very well hidden and
the Easter Egg is of Arnim Zola from
Captain America the First Avenger Zola
was a Hydra scientist who was captured
by and ended up working for shield
secretly he was really infiltrated
shield still having his Hydra beliefs
ultimately Zola would go on to die but
not before transferring his
consciousness into a computer program
this would allow the villain to live
past his death and he would eventually
come back as a villain in Captain
America the Winter Soldier and although
Zola was still alive at this time in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in 1970 this
scene reveals that Zola was working on a
way to transfer his consciousness into a
computer long before his death two years
later in 1972 I'm not sure if anybody
could have spotted this outside of this
visual effects breakdown that revealed
it if you're unfamiliar with the scene
this is when Tony Stark travels back in
time to the shield headquarters with
Captain America in 1970
Captain America goes after the Pym
particles to travel back to the present
time and Tony Stark goes after the
tesseract when Tony Stark is looking for
the tesseract you can see way in the
background that Zola is on a computer
screen and again you really can't see it
except for this visual effects reel so
it's an extremely subtle easter egg
although it doesn't really come as that
big of a surprise Captain America the
Winter Soldier that has the loss of
consciousness reappearing as a computer
program was
directed by Joe and Anthony Russo who of
course directed Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame Captain America the
Winter Soldier was also written by
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
who wrote the scripts for Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame as
well this is something Marvel does like
nobody else they're able to link movies
that are years apart together so subtly
so subtly that it took an Avengers
in-game visual effects breakdown video
just to see so that is the secret
villain Armand Zola Easter Egg in
Avengers in game let me know what you
think about it and let me know if at
some point in time you think we could
see Zola return and the MCU again don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
well fluff